welcome to today's webinar
we will have two speakers today dr sarah
warren from nanostring
followed by jason frazier from presage
biosciences
dr warren will open by presenting a
brief overview of nanostring's digital
spatial profiling platform
geomix dsp and the curated gene
expression panels focused on biomarker
and drug development
dr warren is the senior director of
translational science at nanostring
technologies
where she leverages multiplexed
molecular profiling technologies to
address
key research areas in oncology
immunology and beyond
her role enables her to work with
academics biopharma and clinicians to
identify unmet needs in translational
research
and create novel products for
transcriptional and proteomic profiling
she's also very active in the
immuno-oncology research community
promoting the science and application of
cancer immunotherapy to improve patient
outcomes
thank you so much for joining us today
dr warren we feel really lucky to have
you
and with that the floor is yours
thank you so much i'm delighted to be
here and to be able to tell you about
some of the exciting
new technologies that we're developing
at nanoscreen so as mentioned i'm going
to be talking today really about our
drug discovery tools that we have uh for
both the encounter and the geomics
platforms
so in case anyone is not familiar with
nanostring we are a life science tools
development company
uh and research partner we're founded
and based in seattle washington in the
united states
uh and we have two platforms that we've
commercialized to date
first is our encounter system which is
used for both
transcriptional profiling and we've
recently launched our genomics digital
spatial profiler as well for giving
spatially resolved
uh protein and transcriptional
characterization of tissues
both of these platforms are based upon
our unique chemistry
which relies on direct hybridization of
optical barcodes
to the analyte of interest so in
encounter space we have applied the
technology
to be able to measure rna protein and
dna
and in the dsp digital spatial profiling
space
uh we are able to profile rna and
protein and i'll show you a little bit
about
how each one of those works so first
for encounter space one of the really
nice things about the platform is that
it was designed
to work on formal and fixed paraffin
embedded tissues
and these are samples that are
frequently available as part of
translational or clinical research and
they're very challenging to characterize
with other technologies that may be
based more on enzymes
enabled amplification so the encounter
system
allows profiling of up to 800 distinct
rna targets
and we organize these into panels that
are focused on a specific biology or you
have the ability to design custom panels
for your own particular research
question
but anyway we have um two elements to
our detection technology
the capture probe and reporter probe
each of these are binding to rna
that has been purified from your tissue
sample
and it also works with with blood or
cell culture or any other
sample type where you are trying to
characterize the rna
uh and through this hybridization and
then purification on our end center
technology
we are able to count the presence of
these
bar codes within the sample and each bar
code corresponds to
the presence of a single transcript of a
single analyte
so you can see that it's a quantitative
digital counting mechanism
to understand what that transcriptional
profile is like
in the sample that you're measuring so
we have applied this technology to
all stages of the drug development
spectrum
and you can see how we have designed a
number of panels that we're listing on
this slide
to target specific elements uh along the
research continuum from discovering
the pre-clinical development and
clinical applications
so today we're really going to be
focusing on that first stage the new
drugs and biomarker discovery
and i'm going to tell you about some of
the encounter panels that we have
as well as some of the geometry agents
as well
so um a lot of the uh biology that we
focus on
is uh related to oncology and immunology
uh and one of the panel series we have
that's particularly useful in this space
are what we call our 360 series panels
uh and these are very holistic uh
panels that are looking at sort of the
total
uh total biology related to the tumor
the tumor micro environment and the
infiltrating immune system
but we also have panels that are focused
specifically on different elements like
particular signaling pathways tumor
progression
uh particular immune cell populations or
even metabolism
and in addition any one of these panels
can be customized with up to 55
uh spiken genes that are user selected
to give a little bit more customization
in terms of the research
and data that are generated we have
developed as well
a few clinical assets that can be
deployed on the encounter system
in addition to our ru assays so these
are the tumor inflammation signature
uh which is used for quantifying a
suppressed adaptive immune response in
the context of tumors
it is a way of selecting patients that
are more likely to respond
to anti-tumor checkpoint inhibitors we
have a pan 50 signature which is for
breast cancer subtyping
and we have a lymphoma subtype and
signature as well we've leveraged these
clinical signatures
into our ru assays through uh
some pre-designed reports that we have
360 report or the bc360 report for
breast cancer
so as i mentioned we've we've um are
very excited about these
these 360 panels that we have we've
spent a lot of time curating the content
building out these associated reports
with them uh
and and really trying to embed within
these panels
uh as much interesting biology as the
research community is going to find
useful
we also have a third panel in this
series called our tumor signaling panels
it's very much focused on
signaling pathways within the tumor
as i mentioned we have in addition to
the research reagents we also provide
data analysis services so we have the
full 360
analysis reports as i described that
that will
uh um provide the scores for those
clinical assets that we have
from the research panels uh in addition
it will characterize
uh 27 different immune cell populations
and the number of uh immune pathways in
a very dynamic and interactive format we
can also calculate signal signature
reports
from our three clinical tests and we
also have the ability to do data
analysis on any of our panels
using uh our end solver software
that has been specially designed to
facilitate these analyses
each of these tools are coming from
in-house experts that we have
it's generating publication ready
figures and it's highly interactive
for the end user uh
in addition to the 360 panels we also
have a wide variety of other gene
expression panels some of which i've
listed on this slide
and you can see we're really trying to
cover a broad
survey of biology across different
therapeutic areas
different research questions even
different species
as we've called out specifically the
canine i o panel here
many of these other panels are also
available for use with both
mouse and human samples and
as i mentioned before any of the panels
that we have can be customized with up
to 65
unique user selected genes to really
give that
that really focused research and data
that's going to be specific for your
particular research question
so here's just one example of how we use
the encounter panels for
target discovery and it's a particularly
timely example because we're looking now
uh in uh copic 19 infected lung tissue
so uh last summer when the pandemic was
just emerging
we formed a collaboration with dr robert
colvin at massachusetts general hospital
he had access to lung tissue from
patients that had passed away from the
coping 19 infections
as well as patients who had passed away
from influenza infected blood tissue
he purified rna from each of these and
then he characterized them with
pink history progression and
inflammation panels and was looking for
uh similarities and differences in the
transcriptional patterns t
uh in both of those sample types as a
way of identifying potential drug
targets
for therapeutic development and i'm
showing you just one figure from
the paper that he had here where he
observed that there was a very unique
um t-cell population infiltration into
the copenhagen patients
with a very distinct perivascular uh
distribution
within the lvli there were also unique
genes associated with both the
inflammatory response and vascular
damage and repair uh which manifested as
angiogenesis pathways being activated
so this was a single experiment that he
was able to do he got a very nice
publication out of it in
new england journal um and it was a very
straightforward experiment and very
clean data analysis and you can see
how easy it was for him to identify uh
the
really interesting biology that gave us
more insight into the
underlying mechanisms of infection
the other platform that we have for
doing drug discovery biomarker
development work
is of course our geomics and geomics
digital spatial profiling
platform this is again based upon that
same
uh barcoding chemistry but we really
wanted to be able to apply it now to
understand
where within different tissues we are
seeing expression of particular targets
this is just a very high level overview
of how the assay works
um we are again working with formally
fixed paraffin embedded tissues although
it's also compatible with fresh frozen
or fixed frozen samples and we incubate
the tissue on a slide with
either our bar-coded antibodies or
bar-coded
institute hybridization rna probes
along with fluorescent visualization
markers
we then image the tissue on the
geometric system select regions of
interest for molecular characterization
and expose those regions of interest to
uv light
which then cleaves the barcodes off of
the
off of the analyte detection probes uh
captures them in a
tighter plate where they are then
quantitated
either by an encounter or by an ngs
sequencer
so the real heart of the technology is
based uh
on our ability to control the path of
that uv light
we do it uh using what we call a digital
micro mirror device that is uh
a million little tiny mirrors that are
each independently controlled
and can be uh programmed by the computer
to
either turn on which will let the light
pass through the tissue
or be off which um which doesn't allow
the uv light to go through
and what we can do then is use the
fluorescent images that we're generating
to visualize this issue
to make automatic masks that will
control that path of uv light
so in the top slide in the top right
side of the slide
you can see the tumor specific mask that
we've made
by passing the uv light only through
the tumor cells of this particular
sample which are the yellow cells that
you can see
in the middle image and then we
collected all of the barcodes from that
mask we put them in one well in the
microtiter plate and then we went back
to that same tissue
that same region of interest and we
inverted the map
the mass to make a tumor
microenvironment and now we're
collecting
all of the barcodes from the pan ck
negative cells that are not the tumor
that are present here and we collect
those into a separate well of the
microfiner plate
and quantitate them independently so we
can really understand
where within this tissue we're seeing
particular targets being expressed
and here's just what that data can look
like when you do that on the right side
of this graph
we uh were using the genomics to
characterize this particular sample
uh with a 96 flex rna assay and you can
see very clearly
without even being able to read the gene
names there's very distinct
molecular patterns associated with
um the tumor cells and uh
the non-tumor stromal cells uh within
this sample
so one of the things uh that's been
really powerful about this technology
is that we've been very creative about
how we deploy
the ability to draw these masks on the
tissue
and so i'm showing you here five
different visualization strategies
uh the first and simplest is our
geometric profiling which is just where
we collect everything that's within that
region of interest
as a single sample point and then can
compare it to
other regions of interest within the
same tissue or across
different tissues second is our
segmentation approach which i
previously described to you and then our
rear cell profiling approach is just a
variation of segmentation
but here rather than defining cold
tissue compartments we are using
fluorescent markers to illuminate
particular immune cell populations
such as cd3-t cells or cd68 positive
macrophages
and we collect the transcriptional or
proteome profiles from each of those
cell populations independently
contouring is just as it sounds where we
are defining
uh regions of interest based upon their
distance from a user selected point in
the tissue sample
so we might use it to characterize
distribution gradients across the tumor
tumor micro
environment uh or distance from an
apical surface within a
stratified epithelial layer graded
approach then is the last profiling
mechanism we have where we are doing
unbiased sampling of a region of
interest
to collect the entire transcriptional
profile in distinct
individual wells so that we can more
finely dissect exactly where those
signals are coming from
none of this profiling would be possible
unless we had
the appropriate uh panels for looking at
the analytes that are of interest
to our users and so we have developed um
a number of protein panels uh for the
platform
uh the two that have been most developed
to date are
one for cancer and immunology and a
second for
neuroscience and each of these are
organized uh
into a core plus module format where you
order
uh the core target set which
also contains all of the controls that
you will need to run the asset
and then you can customize it with
additional content specific for your
research question
by adding one or more modules all of the
antibodies that we are
including in our gmx platform have gone
through an extensive testing
uh validation process so you can have a
lot of confidence when you start your
genomics experiment
but those antibodies are going to work
right off the bat for your experiment
and not need a lot of
development work in order to generate
good data
uh the the rna space is another
uh aspect of the genomics platform that
we have been developing extensively
recently we launched our cancer
transcriptome atlas
in the middle of last year this is a
panel that contains 1800 different genes
for characterizing tumor biology again
that immune response
micro environment so in many ways it's
very similar to the 360 panels that i
talked about for encounter
but of course it contains a few more
genes and you have the ability to
customize
those targets and as soon as we launched
this panel we realized that there were
investigators who had questions beyond
cancer and immunology and they really
needed other solutions
so we went back and we developed our
whole transcriptome atlas now which was
uh for characterizing the whole
transcriptome basically 18 000 genes in
human 22 000 genes in mice
it's a non-three prime biased cultured
scriptural profiling because we're
relying on that
uh direct hybridization of the probes to
the target
um so with this we can get complete
coverage of the transcriptome
and again we have the ability to do
customization here which allows us to
characterize
um uh non-in endogenous genes exogenous
genes
synthetic targets non-coding rnas you
know whatever is of interest uh for you
and so one particular application of
that
uh high flex rna profiling channel is
again in the code 19 space
where we were working on a collaboration
with dr david king
again from best general as with bob
closing was involved in this project too
and here we were characterizing uh lung
autopsy tissue from kobe 19 patients
that either had a high level of virus
detectable at the time of their deaths
or low levels of virus
and we did characterization um on these
samples with both
the cta panel and the 60 flex protein
profiling assay
i'm just showing you one data figure
from the paper
where they were using rna scope
from acd to visualize the actual virus
present in these samples
and that's what you see on the far left
side of the slide the the white and pink
image
and then we selected uh in geomic space
uh regions of interest that were virus
high or virus low
um from that tissue and then we
characterized
uh the transcriptional differences
between these two different rois
across five different patients and what
you can see there
on the right side of the slide is the
the volcano plot that shows the
differential gene expression
that was associated with presence of
detectable virus um
in short we saw a lot of uh
uh interferon signaling associated with
the virus but there was not the
uh expected uh localization of t and b
t cells b cells and k cells in those
same regions of interest
which suggests that there's a
dysregulation in terms of the immune
cell
trafficking going on in the example
these results were published recently
in nature communications just a couple
months ago and we look forward to being
able to share more stories about how
genomics is being used for copenhagen
profiling
in the very near future if you're
interested in in that story or any of
the other stories showing geomix
applications
i'd encourage you to go to our website
where we have links to the 38
publications today that use
geomix technology and you can see just a
selection of those
uh journals that are publishing
geometric papers here and you will very
quickly notice that they're very
uh high tier journals across a wide
variety of fields
so i encourage you to go and find the
stories that
match closely with the research that you
are interested in doing
and with that i'm going to wrap up my
portion of the presentation
and i leave you with our vision for how
administering platforms can be used in
the drug discovery process we really
think that there is a place for both
bulk profiling and spatial profiling to
form a research continuum
where we are looking back and forth
across both axes
to understand how how potential drug
targets how biomarkers
uh and how genes and proteins that are
controlling the fundamental biology
are distributed within the clinically
relevant samples that
uh our users are uh able to access and
interested in profiling so thank you so
much for listening
to my talk today and i i'm
i'm very pleased to be able to share the
work with you
all right well now turn to our next
speaker jason frazier of presage
biosciences
jason is the director of scientific
operations at presage a phase zero
clinical research organization
he oversees presage's testing lab and
pre-clinical research lab operations
in support of partner-sponsored clinical
and pre-clinical research
he has spent the past 10 years at
presage working to develop and expand
their assay technologies
prior to joining presage he worked as a
scientist at targeted growth
and at rosetta informatics work research
laboratories working on development of a
lentiviral high-throughput screening
platform
he will be speaking today on deep
mechanistic profiling of immune oncology
drug combinations
and cancer patients using two
complementary platforms
thank you so much for joining us today
jason and the floor is yours
great thank you hello everyone thank you
for joining the presentation today
so first i'd just like to take a minute
to acknowledge
and say that i think we can all agree
that we're very excited about
technologies
like the digital spatial profiling
capabilities in the genomic system that
is being developed at nanastring they're
incredibly powerful
and that they enable in greater and
greater understanding of complex
molecular interactions within the
architecture of tissues
including cancer and so today it's my
pleasure to speak to you all about how
we are using this hyplex
biological readout technology and using
it to
profile samples and applying this
in our early phase zero clinical drug
development studies
the data i'll show you today started
really with a question
and that is what if you could combine
spatial profiling
with a way to precisely expose distinct
areas of a tumor
to different drugs and then evaluate
those responses
and really thinking about this if this
is feasible
um you know thinking about the impact
that we could make
on translational oncology and early drug
development
and think about what such an approach
could mean
for even the future of precision
oncology
and i know that there are certainly
others out there who have thought about
this
so in 2016 the cancer moonshot report
was published by the nci and leading
experts to put forth
recommendations on how to accelerate
cancer research and discovery efforts
in this they identified some of the
unmet needs and key areas
key areas such as translational research
where
currently the rate of success and
translating drug development programs
guided
using pre-clinical models to approved
therapies
is still extremely low at around 10
percent
in this they describe the potential
solutions to this problem
including developing dependable
platforms on which to test
anti-cancer agents to accurately predict
success in patients
including devices that can deliver micro
doses
directly into intact patient tumors
this being a technology that would allow
us to better understand the response
of the intact micro environment and
immune system during research in
translational drug studies
and at presage we have developed
such a platform and the platform that we
have developed
we call sivo
so sibo stands for comparative in vivo
oncology and as its name implies it's a
technology that allows drug developers
to
investigate and compare responses to
drugs
or combinations of drugs within a living
tumor while the tumor is still
intact and in the patient and as you can
see in the
upper left-hand graphic it's a
multi-needle
injection device that is capable of
accessing
and living tumors and delivering up to
eight different micro doses
of investigational drugs or drug
combinations
directly into the patient's tumor the
injection results in distinct
and spatially defined columns of drug
within the tumor as you can see
illustrated in the middle left panel
an important aspect of
to the technology is the code delivery
of
fluorescent microspheres which we call
sibo glow
that remain localized at each side of
the injection and help us to uniquely
identify
each injection site for downstream
sample processing
and analyses once the tumor is
surgically biopsied or recepted the
sample is then cross-sectioned
perpendicular to the injection plane as
you can see in the lower left panel
and we can then use these samples to
generate thin sections
for more traditional
immunohistochemistry
to evaluate biomarker responses like you
see
in the central larger image in blue you
can see the nuclear dappy
stain and in green you can see the more
punctate
fluorescent microspheres that denote
each injection
site which helps us identify each of
these sites
even in cases where we cannot see
an apparent response to the drug
and in red you can now see one of our
tried and true
biomarkers of response cleave caspase 3
which shows us which of the drugs may
induce tumor cell killing
through pathways such as apoptosis we
have a number of different ihc
and nc2 hybridization stains that we're
able to leverage
to assess responses including markers of
cell death
signal transduction immune cells
and also activation status of immune
cells
so now looking at at this slide here
you'll see in the right hand side an
image
of an example of a sibo micro-injection
site
in a patient tumor where the drug has
induced
a classical marker of t cell activation
granzyme b
and upon closer look we even find
cytotoxic t
cells throughout this injection site and
drug exposure zone
attacking the cancer cells so now with
the sibo technology
we are addressing some of the key
components
for improving the success and efficiency
in translational oncology including
these sorts of comparative analysis
of drugs in these spatially defined ways
and within the native tumor
microenvironment
and intact immune system in patients
and we're now able to do this in
patients with
investigational new drugs and
drug combinations with investigational
new drugs
given the spatial aspect of an approach
like ours with shivo
i can see you know you can i think it's
easy to see why our technology
is nicely complemented by a technology
like
nanostrings digital spatial profiling
the ability to now spatially profile
samples like the ones that we generate
exponentially
increases the number of biomarker reads
we can get
from each one of our precious clinical
samples
so now i would like to talk about how we
have begun using
the pi flex spatial readout to cast a
highly
targeted but much broader net to
evaluate tumor response
in sibo-injected patient tumors by
combining
these two spatially resolved
technologies like civo
and geomics we can now look at how
individual patient tumors and immune
cells respond
to different drugs in this sort of high
flex fashion
the ability to retain the architecture
of the tumor in our samples is
absolutely necessary
for the type of spatially defined
analyses we do
with our sibo approach and this is
exactly why we like
digital spatial profiling and why we've
begun layering
geometric analysis on top of our sibo
multiplex drug analysis
using the sort of high plex profiling
panels such as the
cancer transcriptome atlas that sarah
mentioned
earlier gives us you know far greater
information
from each sample than the traditional
more traditional
low throughput immunohistochemistry and
in c2 assays that one can run on these
types of samples
so now by combining sivo and geomixed
uh really if you think about this it's
as if we are putting
a single patient into eight different
arms
of a clinical study at once and then
have the capability to
profile how their tumor is responding
to each of the different treatments and
and now even how
their immune system is responding as
well
so to take this sort of uh synergistic
platform uh technology a step further
the geomex platform really allows us to
stain
for rare cell populations such as t
cells and other immune cells and apply
this digital spatial profiling
specifically within these populations to
compare how they are responding
to the different drugs across the
different treatments so
using uh the dfp panel like the cta
panel which consists of over 1800 gene
targets
we can now generate upwards of over 30
000 different potential biomarker
readouts
in a single study and we can do this
using only a single tissue section
which is really of value to us since it
allows us to preserve a lot of our
precious
clinical samples so as we've begun to
study drugs
that have immunomodulatory properties
in our clinical studies we have found
that using
earlier time points and transcriptional
readouts
gives us far more information on the
activation status
of the immune component and the tumor
microenvironment
than we typically would see running
standard immunistic chemistry
and in c2 assays which are far lower
throughput and low plex
so now that i've shown you how we are
combining these two technologies
such as our placebo and the nanostring
dsp profiling
to investigate the tumor
microenvironment rare immune cell
populations i can show you how we've
used this
this approach to evaluate responses to
some of these more
interesting immunomodulatory drugs like
checkpoint
inhibitors so this is particularly
exciting
application of these two technologies is
we can now begin to gain
more mechanistic insight into how these
types of drugs may act
and act together in combinations
in patient tumors without having to
expose patients to the typical systemic
administration
and levels of these types of powerful
immune modulating drugs
so in the clinical setting in soft
tissue sarcoma we've begun evaluating
checkpoint inhibitors uh including drugs
like
nivolumab an anti-pd1 antibody drug
and we do in fact see responses that are
specific
to the mechanism of action of a drug
like nevo
including the activation and cytokine
secretion
of immune cells specifically within
the anti-pd1 drug injection sites as you
can see here on the right hand
panel we see some specific responses in
the anti-pd-1
versus a more traditional classical
chemotherapy and soft tissue
sarcoma tribected in
upon you know relieving t cells from
checkpoint we can see their activation
and secretion of cytokines such as
interferon gamma
and when we stain our sample to look
further downstream
at activation of macrophage and
dendritic dendritic cell population
we can see things such as an increased
production of related
chemokines like cxel9 and cxcl10
so traditional immunohistochemistry and
in c2 staining provides us with some
insight into the activation status of
the immune component of the tumor
microenvironment
but it is definitely not the whole
picture
and so we've been looking for ways to
evaluate biomarkers of checkpoint
inhibitors
across cell types within the tumor
microenvironment
and looking for ways to evaluate many
potential
markers of activation within that
population
so naturally this leads us to
asking you know can we focus our
analysis
of sibo samples on specific cell
populations
and figure out what other gene
transcripts are changing in these
populations
as they are exposed to different drug
treatments such as
specifically the t cell component the
rare cell profiling capability of the
geomet system
allows us now to directly answer this
question and so using again a cta panel
we can do in-depth profiling of not only
the t-cell compartment but also the
adjacent tumor cells and really any
cells that are present within the tumor
microenvironment
from this we are now generating
numerous biomarker readouts that will
help us
inform how these cells are responding
and activating
when exposed to drugs like checkpoint
inhibitors
this is a look at some of the data from
the first time we applied rare cell
profiling to
one of our soft tissue sarcoma clinical
samples
and we were happy to see that we did in
fact confirm
what we'd expected to see using a cd3
masking strategy in genomics we showed
that in our samples
we could enrich the gene expression
readout
for not only the cd3 gene transcript
but also for many t cell and
inflammation associated genes
so in the left hand violin plots here
you see that the cd3 masking strategy
works and it works quite well
and we can show that enrichment of the
cd3 transcript
within the cd3 specific mask and not in
the
inverse tumor mask and now taking this
another step further
and looking deeper into the data in the
right hand volcano plot
you can see the cd3 mask samples are
again
highly enriched for t cell specific
transcripts
like granzyme b and cd8 and
in the tumor cell mask we see enrichment
for
transcripts that are typically more
associated with tumor epithelium
and many of the other cell types that
are in the tumor micro environment
so what happens when we apply rare cell
profiling
and now look more broadly across
multiple different drugs
and drug combinations in the same
patient tumor
so you can see here in this slide this
is a breakdown now of the top 100 or so
genes
that are regulated across the different
treatments
within the different compartments of
this patient's tumor
so you can see here in the
green rose the cd3 positive
cell masking in the inverse
cd3 negative cells or any cell that is
not cd3 positive
you'll see that in the yellow rows and
the combined
cd3 and cd3 negative cells that would be
basically all cells within the tumor and
tumor micro environment
you can see that as as a magenta row
in the figure and in the left hand
section of this particular heat map
you will see the top most mostly rate
down regulated genes
across treatments that's shown mostly in
the blue colors
in the middle section you see the genes
that are
more variably regulated by treatment or
cell type
and and then on the right hand section
you'll see the genes that are
strongly upregulated by most treatments
as you can see here in the darker red
colorations
upon closer look at this data now
we see some genes that are highly
regulated specifically
by treatment and also by cell type
so now taking a much closer look
again at this data in the green circle
we see significant upregulation
of granzyme b in the t cell compartment
of the io combination treatment site
which included
aldous leuken and nivolumab and
unexpectedly in the yellow circle we saw
a significant upregulation of ido1
in all compartments in this particular
combination of all this leukemia and
nevo treatment
this is potentially a significant
finding in this patient's tumor
given idea one's role in tumor immune
tolerance
and the potential as an early mechanism
for resistance
so again looking at this a little more
specifically and drilling down
even a little deeper into the data again
and the plot on the left
we we can highlight and see the t cell
specific elevation of granzyme b
at the site of all this leuken and the
voldemab combination
and we see this across multiple levels
of the patient tumor
that we analyzed similarly in the right
hand plot we see
increased expression of ido1 within the
tumor microenvironment across now
multiple tumor levels
and we see this at sites of aldis leuken
at sites of nivolumab
and with the most significant
significant
elevation of ido1 occurring within the i
o
combination site itself
so based on these findings with the
geomics
digital spatial profiling data set that
we
were able to produce we then took this
and validated some of these observations
using some
adjacent tissue sections and orthogonal
assays such as in situ hybridization
for either cd3 and granzyme b
or idea one itself in this slide here
i'll just point out
you can see the increase in the granzim
b
expressing t cells specifically at the
site
of the combination of all this leukemia
and the volamab injection
and the sebanjected tumor
and similarly we were also happy to see
that we confirmed
upregulation of ido1 via nc2
hybridization staining and quantitated
this particular response using image
analysis
the overall idea one up regulation
in this patient tumor at the site of the
io combination
is significant compared to all of the
other treatments in this patient's tumor
including another injection site that
contained
a combination of doxorubicin a more
classical chemotherapy
and the volumab and this comparison is
seen
when you are now comparing the two green
bars in this bar chart
so confirming the spatial profiling gene
expression results through
these orthogonal assays gives us a lot
of confidence
in this type of approach and this type
of high plex analysis
and so we were very pleased to see that
we were able to confirm the results
through our labs through these assays
so now just to wrap up here briefly um
you know we're excited about these two
technologies and the way that we can
combine them
for translational research we're really
using them to begin to understand and
gain insight into some of the early
mechanism of action of drugs
like checkpoint inhibitors as well as
the tumor microenvironment response
to these types of drugs when we
introduce them directly
into unique patient tumors
using the data like i just showed you we
can begin to uncover potential
actionable hypotheses for how to combine
drugs
not only for drug development purposes
but really in the future for precision
oncology purposes
so i'll end there uh thank you for
joining the presentation today and thank
you to everyone at nanastring in the
national stream tech access program
for their support in helping us generate
geomix data here early on
and of course a big thank you from the
presage team
to all of you for joining the talk today
oh excellent talk thank you so much
jason really appreciate it um if you
don't mind i have a few questions for
you
um first off yeah what is the typical
time point you evaluate
tumor response for the sibo micro dose
drugs
yeah that's a good question and that's
an important question
as it relates to the types of drugs that
we're studying so
typically in our clinical studies
we are able to remove or biopsy
tumors within an hour and as far out as
120 hours
following the intra-tumoral fevo
microdosing
and and largely this time point depends
on the mechanism of action
of the drug and the type of response
that we're looking to evaluate so for
example
we would select maybe a shorter time
point
for the evaluation if we're interested
in looking at early biomarkers
of resident immune cell activation
great another question here um can you
explain what you mean by phase
zero clinical studies yeah this is
probably a less familiar phase
in clinical and translational studies
phase
phase zero studies are clinical trials
that
have been developed in in response to
the exploratory
ind guidance put forth by the fda
and this guidance allows researchers
to administer sub-therapeutic microdose
quantities
of investigational new drugs and so
we've been able to leverage this
guidance
uh using our sivo uh platform
um in a unique way and that we can
deliver
this micro dose directly to the tumor
and achieve and achieve these spatially
resolved
higher concentrations of the drug
without systemically
exposing the patient to the to that drug
fantastic great overview and one final
question
how large are the spatially restricted
drug response zones in the tumor tissue
and how do you select your areas for
analysis such as placement of
aois or areas of interest for dsp
yeah so the typical drug response zone
or drug exposure zone within that
column of drug that we introduce into
patient tumors is about
anywhere from three sometimes four
millimeters in diameter
the co-injection of our sibo glow
microspheres which i
pointed out earlier in the talk they're
the small
foresting microspheres that stay
localized
at the sites of injection these really
enable
us to identify each one of those
drug exposure zones or injection sites
after we
cross section the tumor and after we
thin section
the fixed tumor for immunohistochemistry
and other assays like geomics
so by using these
fluorescent tracking microspheres it
allows us
to find each injection site and then
place areas of interest
like we do in the geomic system
and in some cases we can leverage
an adjacent tissue section that maybe
has a stain of particular interest for a
biomarker
that we can also leverage to uh place
areas of interest for uh types of
analyses like gl mix
all right great thank you so much and
with that i think we're at time for the
presentations but
i wish to thank both speakers again so
much for sharing their
insights with us and i hope everyone has
a good day